what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are picking up with the immortal Thor
we're actually covering the first two
issues of this now issue number one
doesn't really have a whole lot going on
in it one of the cool things that does
happen here is Loki restores the bifrost
bridge using basically magic because
Loki can do that kind of stuff I mean if
you ever wondered why it is he didn't
restore it earlier well because you know
Comics but what Thor ends up doing is he
basically travels back to Earth because
of his ability to access the bifrost
bridge now this is where things go wild
because as he gets here and really with
his return he kind of celebrates among
Humanity right he's kind of been like
the missing Sun that the human race
hasn't seen for quite some time and so
he kind of spends time among Humanity
does his own thing but then as he's
spending the evening standing on the
Statue of Liberty the whole thing is
suddenly struck by lightning now what's
so crazy about this is that when that
happens this gigantic figure emerges
basically attacking Thor now this guy
basically gives us like these huge Clues
on what's going on with him right he
says I come to you from utgard the stoed
land that is the land of true things I
come to shatter thy false World apart I
am tanos or tonos or whatever you want
to call him the utgard Thor now people
who are very knowledgeable about Marvel
Comics when I say very knowledgeable I
mean like have been reading for a couple
decades or so will know what utgard is
but most of you probably don't and it is
a really really cool place that never
gets talked about so Thor of course
responds exactly the way that you would
expect him to right he basically calls
this guy out and a lot of this has to do
with the fact that Thor is a traditional
superhero right it's what superheroes do
but it's also because Thor has no clue
who he's messing with here because this
guy is an elder god Thor literally
summons all this power of the lightning
and it does nothing to this guy right it
doesn't even harm him in the slightest
it's just kind of whatever and this guy
literally shrugs it off now at that
point we switch over to Gaia now Gaia in
all this and I'll make sense of all this
here in a second because it's really
really cool it's going to blow your mind
Gaia ends up meeting with somebody else
whom we can't see and all that happens
is this person says the wheel has turned
the wheel turns our brother walks in the
world again and only your son bars the
path of his rage is all as you wished it
to be sister Gaia and she responds in
saying little is as I wished it to be
brother but I would have unlocked what I
sealed long Millennia ago if there were
other options and this person responds
in saying you well recall the last time
we were all abroad Echoes of it ring in
dark Legend some yet use our names as
Talisman I recall the amus screamer and
did not the thunderer fight a tanos in
his past now of course she responds in
saying that was basically a troll he was
using the same name but this guy
responds and he says Thor will be tested
by more than trolls now as he was before
long ago when he journeyed to the utgard
hall in his youth that's a massive clue
and as before if he breaks if he falls
if he fails to be what he must be it
will Mark the end of all that is the
rule is clear all things must live and
grow or wither and die the age of
Marvels can be no exception and then
they kind of go back and forth for a
little bit and we end up finding out
that this guy is actually the utgard
Loki so what in the world is going on
with these because this is just the
first issue right it's like what in the
world is going on with these guys okay
the Elder gods are ridiculously
overpowered but what's so funny about
this is these are new introductions by
aling we've never seen these guys before
so here's the way all this stuff works
right Thor and Odin and Loki and those
guys you can kind of refer to them as
effectively New Gods the Elder gods are
like really old school and really
overpowered so in the very early days of
Earth you had what was called the Demi
urge which was basically like uh Earth's
biosphere right the essence of life on
Earth and what it did is it spawned all
these Elder Gods one of these Elder Gods
named set had realized that if it
consumed other Elder Gods it could
absorb their power and so the result was
that basically every single elder god on
Earth just descended into absolute
Madness attacking each other killing
each other and consuming their power
Gaia was one of the very few Elder gods
that did not devolve into this level of
degeneracy what she ended up doing was
actually basically getting herself
knocked up with an elder god named a
tomb what this guy did is he went around
and consumed all the Elder Gods except
for like cathon and set cathon a lot of
you guys know from like the Scarlet
Witch Mythos right the super powerful
evil demon that's always trying to take
over Scarlet which's body and use her as
a vector on Earth this guy took off to
the flickering Realms then you had set
who took off to the serpent sea I'm
pretty sure but they basically live in
different dimensions the bigger point
that I'm making here is the power of
even people like Odin with the full Odin
force is dwarfed by the power of the
Elder Gods these guys are on a whole
different level and that's what Thor
figures out incredibly fast right like
when he attacks tanos with this
lightning bolt nothing really comes out
of it right I mean literally the guy's
just kind of standing there and he even
makes fun of him right even starts
screaming at him right like you would
strike me with the storm puny micro God
the meager Lightnings you command are
nothing to one such as I for I am tanos
who was the god of thunder when the
Thunder first spoke he says tanos who
holds the wheel of fate in his hand now
that's another major clue of what's
going on and this is why Al uing in
Marvel Comics right now is kind of
rewriting everything so a lot of you
guys looking at this person right off
the bat will say he looks familiar and
if you're an old school reader of like
the alphal flight series back before
started to suck when Chris Claremont
wrote the comic we were introduced to
beings called the ones who sit above in
Shadow and these were just crazy
powerful guys it tied into the cycle of
Ragnarok right like the idea of like
Asgard being destroyed and all the
asgardians dying it's a cycle right like
it happens all the time they always end
up being destroyed by whatever Manner
and whatever means they're always reborn
but all that life energy of the
asgardians was consumed by those who sit
above in Shadow we never really knew
what their actual origin was or where
they came from and in fact during the
Loki Series right the last days of Loki
leading up to Secret Wars in 2015 the
closest we ever got was like Loki
hypothesizing that maybe they were
beyonders but there was never really any
definitive answer the biggest moment
with them came during the events of Thor
Ragnarok or Thor disassembled when Thor
basically destroyed the world tree of
idril and was believed to have killed
them only to find out that they weren't
actually dead what seems to be going on
here is that Al Ying is rewriting all
this Mythos in such a way to effectively
say that the ones who sit above in
Shadow are basically Elder Gods who were
locked away somewhere along the line we
don't definitively know right we won't
know until aling basically gives us like
the conclusion of all of this and it all
basically wraps up but the bigger Point
here is that it would make logical sense
the power of the ones who sit above in
Shadow is Way Beyond The Power of
virtually any and all as guardian God
who exist out there including Thor and
Odin but what's really crazy about this
is that Thor in addition to his Thor
Force summons the power of Odin right
the Odin power I.E the Odin Force so in
effect his power is more or less
Amplified several times over and even
then he's still not able to defeat this
guy and again he makes fun of him right
like the god of ants sends a single
spark against me and cannot even hit me
with it now this is the thing behind
this Thor not trying to attack him in
the here and now and this is a testament
to the power of the Odin force and is
actually a new development that we'
never really seen before at least the
Thor power and the Odin power combined
together Thor basically rips open What's
called the yawning void and the yawning
void is literally a portal to the far
Shore right The Place Beyond all time
and space just before you get to the
white hot room where the Phoenix Force
resides in effect Thor is sending this
guy to the realm we celestials and
really gods of the highest order all go
to die but what's crazy here is we're
told it's not going to kill this guy
it's basically a way to just kind of
keep him out of the way for a little
while but he will come back he will
return the kigger about all this is that
as most of you guys know who are
familiar with the Thor Mythos
specifically with the Odin Force the
Odin force is a massive source of power
but when you use it it requires you to
rest right the all sleep the Odin sleep
whatever it is that you want to call it
so while tanus is basically sucked in
through the yawning void and literally
sent to the far Shore where he's
effectively yanked away and trapped for
what's probably going to end up being
like the next issue or maybe a few
issues after Thor uses what little
remnant of the Odin Force he has left
combined with what little energy he has
left to kind of fix everything in New
York that was destroyed during the fight
between the two of them and then
promptly begins to pass out now he
doesn't completely and totally pass out
but this guy's exhausted he's drained of
energy right he just can't really go on
and so what happens is Loki suddenly
appears now Loki did appear in the first
issue of course when he restored the
bifrost bridge but Loki in recent years
in Marvel Comics has been very enigmatic
and Marvel has largely been toying with
this idea that Loki has a much bigger
role to play in the Marvel Universe than
we were ever really led to believe right
like the God of stories and so on and so
forth Loki's whole escapades traveling
with Adam Brasher and the Defenders to
like the varying Realms of magic and
godly power and fighting the beyonders
and so on and so forth but we didn't
really know what the deal was with Loki
and even now we don't fully understand
what's so interesting here is that with
the exchange between the two of them
Loki simply just pops up and says will
you trust me and when Thor asks what are
you talking about he says Loki for one
your timing is excellent lady cth saw my
plight correct she's the one that
basically took the place of heimall
after heimall died and his response is
no but then she's the guardian of the
Rainbow Bridge not the babysitter of the
Odin son and he says I fear even the
sharpness of the tongue cannot cut
through this fog descending around me
and so where Loki surmises that Thor is
beginning to succumb to the Odin sleep
so it's only a matter of time before he
basically just collapses due to sheer
exhaustion the response of Loki is Thor
you have to answer the question will you
trust me and Thor is a little hesitant
here right he says like when the
trickster ask for trust it often means
trouble the response of Loki is this is
important Thor you must answer and it
must be the right answer will you trust
me as a loyal subject of Asgard the
response of Thor yes I trust your
loyalty Loki's next question will you
trust me as your sibling who loves you
the response of Thor of course of course
I do we are Ken Loki I brought you back
from Death because I missed you you will
always have a place in my heart yes I
trust you as my own blood the response
of Loki one more question Thor he says
this one is the most important on this
the future rests will you trust me even
as your enemy and Thor becomes very
hesitant here because one of the things
that had happened with Loki over the
years and this is something to be aware
of
Loki up until the events of Siege on
Asgard at the end of the dark rain kind
of branding initiative that Marvel had
when Norman Osborne and his ilk and so
on tried to attack Asgard and Brockton
Oklahoma there's a whole history behind
it we don't need to go into it Loki
effectively sacrific his life when that
happened he ended up returning right now
when he came back he basically reformed
his ways he came back as a good guy he
wasn't fully trusted by the people
around him but it was like a big status
quo for his character character I mean
good guy is a loose term when it comes
to Loki so he was like less of a bad guy
than he had traditionally been but what
he's putting out here is I'm returning
to my villainous ways but even in
knowing that I'm going back to being the
old villainous Loki that I always was do
you still trust me and the response of
Thor is yes Loki even as my enemy I
trust you so be what thou must be and do
what thou must do now this all feeds
into the nature of Loki as like the god
of stories because one of the things
that Marvel's kind of been alluding to
is this notion that Loki kind of has the
ability to alter reality almost on this
kind of universal scale by basically
manipulating stories as they get told
right kind of basically seeding exactly
how things progress now I'm
hypothesizing here there's no direct
indication that's the case it's just
kind of what I'm picking up on from what
Marvel's been talking about over the
years but that's when Loki takes on a
totally new form that we've never seen
before right Loki the teller of tales a
whole new personality a lot of old
school fans were really irritated they
wanted to see like the original Loki
come back like the horns coming out of
his head and that kind of thing but such
as it is whatever this form is that Loki
now has and whatever power it entails
will become stupendously important to
the future of the Thor Mythos but with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace